First up.
Sometimes you got to have it out
news program to news program.
And recently John Oliver gave us a little shout out
on Last Week Tonight.
Take a look.
They watch Tucker the same way I watch
The drew Barrymore show.
First time for fun.
Second, to figure out how she can possibly successfully
pull off a segment in which a child makes a Shirley temple
while Stanley Tucci, quietly drinks, the entire glass
of wine on a screen in the background.
I don't know how you work your magic Drew
but I want to learn you were advancing this form.
(audience laughing)
I'm going to take that as a compliment, sir
from the man and the group of people
who took the form as far as it could be taken.
I can't love The John Oliver show more
but keep your eyes on us guys.
'Cause we're coming for ya.
Last Week Tonight, shoots here at the CBS broadcast center
where we shoot our show.
We've already staked our claim
over your domain in the building.
(car engine roaring)
Suck it Oliver.
(audience clapping)
That used to be your entrance before you gave it up.
Are you coming back to the building?
Let's do that.
(laughing)
I loved y'all over show.
I was watching it.
When that happened, I screamed out loud in my living room.
The fact that John Oliver
and his amazing team knows we exist Rossi.
I can't be more excited.
I mean, they really did advance the forum.
Oh my gosh.
They've changed the game completely.
And they're watching, hi.
I'm like.
(laughing)
They got great taste.
Up next, we got a story about Nike.
Now I don't know if you remembered Drew
but back in like 2019
they faced a little criticism
for their treatment of pregnant athletes
that they partner with.
Because some of them, when they got pregnant
they like didn't renew their contracts.
Well they've taken positive steps to change their pay policy
and to provide more protections to athletic mothers.
And now Glamour reports, they're paying tribute to them now
in their new maternity ad.
And guess what?
We've got a clip.
What is an athlete?
Someone who moves< sounds like you.
Someone who gets it done, no matter what you do that.
(audience clapping)
Yeah, this is I think a great example
of the company hearing the public and addressing it.
Having a baby is like the most miraculous thing
that your body can do, you know?
And so talk about athletic.
I'm like to the founders of Nike
how do you think you got here?
All right.
So congratulations for waking up.
(laughs)
But she said--
If you're not a super elite athlete, but just like,
'Thanks God,' wow.
If you're not a super elite athlete,
but just want to squeeze in a light workout
with a good playlist in your ears,
check this new feature out on Spotify.
Pop Sugar reports that you can a custom playlist
inspired by your pet.
That's right.
This is the new trend.
It's super fun, easy to do.
You go to pets.byspotify.com and select your pet dog
cat, guana, hamster bearded, dragon, you know
and you give some details on your pets attitude
and personality upload a photo.
And just like that
you've got a playlist to match your pets vibe.
Yeah, I did it.
I picked for Selena and you go in and you talk about
they ask you questions about their personality.
She's like part Chihuahua, part hippopotamus--
Oh my God.
She's just total slow-mo.
And so I answered questions about her personality
and they put together a playlist
and it turns out Selena is in her feelings,
because it's like,
"You're Still The One," by Shania Twain.
(laughing)
I wanna do this.
I love this though, because whenever I leave the house
I leave music on for them meditation music.
Because I think they're probably stressed out
that I'm not there.
They don't care.
Maybe I should leave some music on for them too
I'm going to leave on Twisted Sister.
(upbeat music)